at any time of year a visitor to India
can be overwhelmed by its beauty and
color but a visitor in late fall is a
special unfortunate the temperature will
have filled out the monsoons will have
not yet begun and Diwali the festival of
lights is at hand
Diwali is too many Indians what
Christmas is to Christians in essence it
commemorates the victory of the forces
of light over the forces of darkness to
experience it fully get up before dawn
and head for the flower markets here
flower vendors work feverishly to create
Garland's of fragrant jasmine that
Indians will use to adorn their homes by
dawn they'll be sold out next head for
one of the temples but go early later on
in the day they'll be packed on your way
over you may see a curious sight people
hunched in front of their doorways
pouring colored sand on the ground the
sand takes the shape of a lotus blossom
a symbol of welcome and today millions
of symbols of welcome will grace the
nation's doorways
indeed Diwali is all about sharing if
you're staying in a private home don't
be surprised if the neighbors show up
with plates of delicious holiday treats
it's also customary for families to go
to the tempest together on this day they
all been dress and find new outfits
purchased especially for Diwali and if
their outfits inspire you head for a
sari shop shops are open on Diwali and
Indian silks are justifiably famous for
their beauty they're just one of the
ways India spruces up and gets into the
holiday spirit so this is an occasion
for all of us to rejoice and be with the
family and enjoy all the good things in
life so we buy good clothes and make
good food and everywhere there are
lights if you head to major commercial
districts throughout India you'll find
colorful displays comparable to
Christmas lights in western cities
some cities also put on spectacular
public displays of fireworks like this
one in Delhi but no matter where you are
there are smaller more intimate
fireworks displays a long day of
celebrations is coming to an end and
it's going out with a bang
you